hey I'm Lorraine and I'm licensed mrs.
Earth's Mightiest show brought to you by
Walmart yeah we're gonna be talking
about all the big stuff happening in the
Marvel Universe that you are hardcore
Fanning about and it's flippin marvel
studios Avengers infinity light coming
out of your mouth
puppies kittens joy they all love it
teracle yeah oh my goodness we're gonna
be we're gonna be talking all about this
film and and just bringing you all types
of content and getting into some Marvel
game and a whole lot more but Avengers
infinity war let's talk let's o M G act
this the film coming out April 27th you
know what that is
tomorrow tomorrow what are you doing
tomorrow I know what you're doing
tomorrow you're gonna go see my shoes
Avengers if anyone if you don't we'll
know everyone is flippin talking about
it all up in my cellphone sure just
saying like I want to watch this trailer
a million times oh we could mean we
can't watch a million times it's been
viewed a million times other people
what's another by us let's watch right
now alright let's go to our living room
but remember in Doctor Strange when
everything comes around I love the
entire time I knew him he only ever had
one god yes one food
to wipe out half the universe if he gets
all the Infinity stones she can do it
with the snap of his fingers just like
that tell me his name again
Santos come on no one takes up a helmet
like this also I also know that gold
armor though is beautiful I love
spider-man Midtown Nigeria
she's coming to us
we have a dance once if it is yeah
people underestimate how good Tony Stark
is that motivational speeches
that's cool at this plant ears I think
it's good except it sucks so let me do
the plan and that way it might be really
so shiny
Wow my society new
can you hear them cutting bucks honestly
all of the dorm elijah in in a flying
car is all I've ever used
I love it
[Music]
still exist on the rough time of all on
you cuts the tesseract perfectly
balanced
as all things should be
I'm really excited until gonna pass on
this I know that ebony now actually this
this is this is it right here's the cell
you have is when Captain America like
goes to pick up Mjolnir and it kind of
like yeah he can hold them off grabbing
his pinky and a pointer finger
I'm Peter by the way dr. strange Oh
using your made-up names then I am
spider-man that's a that's a fun do I
see community that he was still fun
maybe just as fun as the other the other
do as you mentioned he's falling to
adventure that's what he's falling
through that's falling through space
adventure what was your favorite part
the trailer you know what really my
favorite part is the keep that said I
was like alright we're getting snow my
favorite part is you're through the park
tiny Gamora hand dad Thanos somebody
feels of but if you want to have even
more feels you guys should check out
these interviews I did with the cast of
the film right now it's been 10 years of
films 10 years 18 films 18 films have
all been leading up to assembling this
many Avengers would you be up for some
corporate training exercises just to
really work on your teamwork yes sure
trained us are you ready yeah fine
oh okay you can also build a fire if we
can get sustained
can you stop afar from scratch okay so
you're gonna go to the person on your
right and you're gonna tell them one
thing that you admire about them
[Music]
all day the goggles it's the best I love
your humility your new haircut admire
your honesty thanks man
we showed that I have looked up to you
in your work for many many years and
it's a pleasure to work with you trying
to get the temperature of this room down
and I'm gonna stop blushing you know
okay one thing that I admire about EF is
his honesty that's a nice one thing I
admire about Joe is his bravery
now I'm gonna say something back the
honesty thing is about that we're
constantly teasing this boy because
apparently he's the sport of horse body
he's not really it's just a joke but
he's honest as well he's 21 and he's got
this huge gig in his hand Lee was such
maturity and he's brilliant as isn't all
his work and I'm watching him to throw
the comforter back in a new possible
going that child is only where you were
boy than you were channeling something
that was amazing it was very very moving
bring it please
thanks bye that's funny was it right
there we go you should do them with the
Avengers next time right there you go
well you guys all go see the film Marvel
Studios Avengers infinity war in
theaters on April 27 thank you thank you
very much appreciate it well that was
fun appreciate it
[Music]
you get mr. shook well there's a logged
on because you taught me pet we you can
see to the Infinity stones yeah there
are a lot of infinity says so let's
review where have we seen the Infinity
stones because we've seen them a lot in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe
so we first got tasty and famous stones
and Marvel Studios The Avengers we saw -
actually that's right we have the
tesseract which contains the space stone
correct and then we also had a Loki's
scepter which held the mind stone which
is now in the forehead of vision that's
right so then the next one we saw was
actually the ether mm-hmm or if you're
me you say at a Third Reich which
Malekith of course had and then Volstagg
and sniff gave Titov on the blender are
keeping we're tracking them all down
okay yeah and then we also had the
guardians of the galaxy who tried to get
that orb away from Ronan the orb
contained an infinity stone that was the
Power Stone that's right and there's now
with ins and R with the Nova prime yeah
so that's our five oh no our fifth is
almost moto inside his I have automotive
necklace there's the time stone which
used to imprison Dormammu in an infinite
loop
well not infinity eventually gave up
otherwise he'd still be there yeah mhm
and that's five but we still have these
soul stones you have not seen yet I'm so
excited
I mean it's vid there's a lot of
theories wherever where it could be and
it's very exciting so I can't wait to
find all the answers good feel to it um
you know what else I'm into we don't see
into Marvel games yeah hey you know who
we should have I jump in here I think I
know Josh the leg twice in a row
something right bro so there's a ton of
stuff coming out we've been talking a
little bit before last week Marvel
Avengers and fitty or has cool content
coming to games what's up for us this
week yeah well it's the biggest Marvel
gaming event in history yeah and they
just talked a little bit about Lego
Marvel vs. superheroes - we got a new
level and new characters which is
something insane because the game
already has a ton of new levels already
every character
but I could I can go on for hours
talking about this game but I want you
guys to get a feel for it and play it
yourself so I got from a friend from a
friend future fight for you yeah all
right we're starting strong with Thanos
yeah right trail so I want to show you
guys some costumes so if you head over
to team for me let's go to team and this
content is available now for everyone to
play we got a sneak peek at this a week
ago
let's go over to Captain America see his
new suit yeah oh bearded cap all day
every day Tony I saw those were kind of
shields and the trailer a gift from King
each other
and if we go to Black Widow and then we
have a Iron Man this is a free game
playing on a mobile device not a console
which is like blowing me away
yeah the art for this game is so
beautiful yes it is vibrant it is right
there
Iron Man Google Play app store these are
the costumes which are beautiful more to
be unearthed
as you continue now let's do a level how
about that yeah let's let's get into
this let's get into the challenge of
Thanos oh okay I'll do that
so let's go to challenge oh we have a
legendary battle sleeveless Thanos right
there I'm gonna go normal because no new
yes game gonna work your way out gotta
make you don't want to be embarrassed a
game so yeah let's what you want to do
you want to do a battle of what Kondo
yeah the bell well I'm just I want to
know what it's about
yeah I want to see it too all right we
got Black Widow on deck all right we're
gonna start we're gonna get to the game
here we go all this go Sheree right here
mmm
you wanna skip I want to skips didn't
want to give too much away I want to get
let's get right into it but I felt great
about Sheree yeah but now you know
series in the future faith and if you
haven't laid future fight before
basically it's a game that's fast paced
it's always there and then you have to
basically push the action button on the
right as fast as possible moving away
from combat as fast as you can
oh you have skilled trees on your right
that you can use one through five you
can choose up to three characters to
play at the same time and activate a
power that lets you use all their
together their powers together
that's just like I'm blown away look at
this here we go you're going right in
like Edison when I tell you people
running toward you they're about to
fight each other is only
Oh Maron okay so I know there's a lot
happening I did not expect okay let's
get and so y'all talked about this and
I'm gonna try not to there's so much
damage right here okay so tell me about
how the specials work yes
the great question so the specials if
you were basically to choose three let's
say go for three it's a special attack
if once you utilize that it's a
cool-down wait 12 seconds to use it
again but the special attacks use more
damage than your regular attack so
here's one through five what I would
recommend doing as a player is using
them all as fast as you can because the
cooldown will basically come back and
you can use them again you have to watch
out for the red marks on the ground
because that will attack you and you
don't want to be a hit basically there
we go bloom so how does it work can you
use team elements in this sort of
gameplay or are you solo yes so in this
legendary event you're basically just as
Black Widow in previous campaigns that
you might use you can definitely choose
up to three characters or even more
sometimes and able to switch out and use
those those character so you can choose
who your favorite are so you can do a
scarlet witch and the vision mix and you
can choose a cap and a black panther
which would be my thing okay okay you
use your thumb make should look at the
screen
oh no there are big bad people coming
for me tap screen okay and now it's the
boss now basically three minutes and 40
seconds to defeat these bosses challenge
failed well I took that from you at the
wrong moment I'm sorry I'm let's
practice time Thank You Josh so much for
stopping by you guys can learn more
about all of the awesome Marvel games
that have infinity war content over at
Marvel games on social media and of
course tell us what you thought of
today's show and hash tag Earth's
Mightiest show maybe tell us what Marvel
character you'd like to play as in one
of these awesome game engine tricks yeah
a lot of tips and tricks also please go
see Marvel Studios Avengers infinity war
in theaters tomorrow get in your eyes
tomorrow it'll be so cool and that's it
were to play video games I'm Lorraine
and I'm Langston I'm Josh
your universe thanks for watching
Earth's Mightiest show if you like this
please like this and subscribe to the
model channel or click that box over
there to see our last episode I just
want to do this
destroy